in washington number three house
republican liz
chaney is blasting her colleagues who
say it's time to replace her
for the first time yesterday the house
gop whip called for cheney to be
demoted for publicly opposing former
president trump
nancy cordes is at the white house where
the party squabble is getting attention
from president biden
nancy what's this all about anthony what
this
is about is whether gop lawmakers will
tolerate
having someone who is not an abject
trump loyalist
in party leadership and increasingly it
appears
they will not now president biden
himself is weighing in
saying the gop appears to be locked in a
struggle
over its very identity
significant sort of mini-revolution
going on the republican party that is
how president biden
framed the gop fight over republican
congresswoman
liz chaney it seems as though the
republican party
is trying to identify what it stands for
chaney's leadership position
is in danger because she told the truth
repeatedly
in a new op-ed she once again calls out
former president trump's false claims
that the 2020 election was a fraud and
stolen
she urges gop colleagues to steer away
from the dangerous and anti-democratic
trump cult of personality in a statement
mr trump called cheney a warmongering
fool
and said new york's elise stefanik would
be a far superior choice
for gop conference chair president trump
has fought tirelessly
to deliver results for all americans
stefanik is a loyal trump ally who voted
to challenge november's election results
on wednesday she thanked him for his 100
percent support
one day after gop leader kevin mccarthy
appeared to seal chaney's fate in this
hot mike moment
i think she's got real problems i i've
had it with
i've had it chaney survived one removal
vote after she voted to impeach mr trump
in january
but her gop critics have only gotten
louder
and even longtime defenders senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
wouldn't engage when asked about her 100
percent of my focus
is on standing up to this administration
another removal vote
is likely to come next week on wednesday
here is the bottom line right now on the
right
it pays to embrace former president
trump's false claims about the election
gop lawmakers who do find that they get
increased fundraising halls
and of course more love from his base
and all of that is seen
as key to winning back the house in 2022
which is
why tony liz cheney's high profile
dissent
is seen as such a problem yeah for some
it's about the numbers for others it's
about their own conscience nancy thank
you very much